the Joe Rogan experience Oh Clinton that
was a real painting that was a painting
in Jeff know how crazy this Epstein
story is in Jeffrey Epstein's house in
New York City which was 70 million
dollars worth 70 million that someone
gave him somebody gave it to him okay
whatever I have friends I get it he's
got a painting of Bill Clinton in a
dress pointing at him let's Hillary
Clinton's dress well whoever's dress it
is it's Bill Clinton but it might have
been Monica Lewinsky dress is it the
same one that Hillary won it could be so
weird but that was in his living room
it's so weird so in his living room he
had a painting of Bill Clinton dressed
up like a woman I think he had that
George Bush won - have you seen that
it's almost like they held stuff over
these guys to the point where they get
humiliated they're mocking them so if
that guy came you like if bill came over
to his house he would see that he would
see like you're my [ __ ] [ __ ] you're my
[ __ ] I don't care if you the former
president you're my [ __ ] I still don't
think he'd show you the videos I still
don't think he committed suicide
of course you don't because he didn't
yeah first of all and that's not what do
you think Jamie I'm not like a big
conspiracy get Michael badan that
[ __ ] guy from that HBO toss to be
autopsy serious yeah he talks about it
like in-depth he's like no these are
injuries consistent with someone who's
been choked the way it's also the
position of the cut it's all lower like
when you hang yourself it goes up like
that it's almost choking this
[ __ ] off hey I think Harvey
Weinstein's the next to go just too much
[ __ ] yeah we talked about this yesterday
right denied it with Michael Shermer who
did I talk about this with Lex was it
Michael what'd he say I don't know Mom
I've heard that argument before but I
think that he's got more to lose than he
does to gain because if he says
something like yeah all those Hollywood
starlets they all suck my dick and
that's I think I'm famous
it sort of reinforces he was a monster
that he was a monster
but also shows they were playing the
game they were playing the game but that
games illegal and so the whole
somebody's in jail for the rest of his
life is because that games legal if he's
already in there so if he goes hey I'm
not on this monster like this celebrity
she did this with me for years who this
Geoffrey Epstein's Hollywood pipeline
ran straight to Harvey Weinstein
but I would make up a bunch of stories
about aliens now that Harvey's in the
pokey probably for the rest of his life
out if I ran some of them dubious
websites all day off [ __ ] I would start
writing the most ridiculous stories I am
related to someone who proposition by
Harvey Weinstein said he could make her
a star sounds like your cousin was a
dumbass no it was in Ohio she had no
idea do your research girl was there no
Google back in this [ __ ] it might
have been actually Shane time she could
have been [ __ ] Wonder Woman you
waiting back in the day Wonder Woman he
made people famous Whitney Cummings
talks about it she has a really funny
way of putting it she like well I always
told the truth he did he really did it
for him like if he told me she sucked my
dick I'm gonna put you in this movie
they were in the movie we're in the
movie and that was his reputation like
wow crazy but then again how does a guy
like him ever [ __ ] at 10 by put him in
movies I put him in movies and you
imagine how stunned he must have been
like with imagine you're banging like
some of the most famous hottest women in
the world and you're you're this monster
look you look terrible you look terrible
he's like an experiment right he was so
vile well doesn't he have Corona pretty
sure they moved in the hospital Dave
Chappelle had a [ __ ] hilarious
take on that he goes very few dudes we
look at him and go oh yeah he rapes that
wasn't that belly room comedy special
that he did it was Walker God it's so
crazy
he's so foul looking but if a guy like
him like grew up in that Hollywood
system that's probably he
probably you know like a really extreme
version of how they all did it okay yeah
he's not the first one know that cat did
the casting couch is an expression for a
reason correct it was real it's a huge
porno channel to this day I mean butt in
but we know that that happened right
it's yeah it's gross
uh-huh a hundred percent I'm not I'm not
endorsing it I'm just saying we know it
of it as a historical reality you know
just like we know barbarians used to be
real we know as a historical reality the
casting couch was a real thing Gotti's
file but uh he's got everything he's got
pock marks he's fat he's balding nothing
is good roast look and he doesn't look
compassionate and doesn't look friendly
it's all those things but Italy in a
small dick but it's also it's like
there's just like [ __ ] vortex of
things that are happening everything's
all happening together and this guy
figured out that there's a system if you
get people attention to make them
families and you can make a lot of money
if you make good choices and you're
smart around how you do it and you
control your addiction just enough to
keep making movies whoa he's with a
bunch of young starlets he just looks
like yeah complete [ __ ] just monster
[Applause]